thanks to brilliant for sponsoring this
video use the link in the description to
start learning math science and computer
science
one intuitive step at a time
like most places on earth thailand has
had a strange
year its largest city bangkok is the
world's number one most visited city
measured by international arrivals as
the pandemic spread across the globe
it felt an even greater impact than
other well-traveled cities like paris
london and dubai markets nightclubs and
temples
were now suddenly empty after teeming
with foreigners for years non-stop
but only after a brief calm period of
strictly enforced curfew
were the usual swarm of visitors
replaced with a new one
pro-democracy protesters thousands of
loosely organized students flooded the
streets of bangkok
defying the emergency lockdown orders to
incite change
long overdue they ask for the
resignation of the prime minister
and reforms to the powerful monarchy
currently
anyone found to have defamed insulted or
threatened thai royalty
can be jailed for years while the king
spends much of his time relaxing at his
villa in germany
paid for by the thai public one of the
country's vocal opposition parties was
legally dissolved by the courts in
february
but while thailand's current lack of
tourists is highly unusual
these protests are not the least bit
one of the few consistencies in thai
politics is their extreme turbulence
the country has cycled through more
governments than almost anywhere else in
the modern world
this timeline shows every coup and
attempted coup
since 1910 roughly 21
though there have been so many that
experts disagree on the precise number
notable is not just the sheer number but
also the frequency
the longest a single government has
maintained power
is 15 years and just twice in the entire
period
only three other nations have had more
constitutions
haiti venezuela and the dominican
republic
but there's a less obvious reason for
thailand's instability
one that has nothing to do with the
monarchy democracy
or even politics whatsoever
looking at a map you can tell a lot
about a country
take away all labels markers and
otherwise human generated data
and you can still identify the
ingredients of a nation
how big or small it is which rivers or
oceans it has access to
who its neighbors are climate latitude
forestation shape and so on all of these
things can affect a country's political
stability
a small european nation situated between
two large
powers and land masses you can expect
plenty of invasions
and it's no surprise that this hunk of
snow has been well protected from attack
but what you can't tell from looking at
a map is a country's concentration of
power
big or small much more important when it
comes to stability
is where decisions get made how many
places
and how far apart they are of course in
no nation
is power truly divided evenly it always
concentrates in pockets
just as water droplets naturally attract
and combine
this is no surprise civilization in
general develops unevenly
once cities are founded they experience
network effects
when there's a critical mass of energy
transportation buildings and jobs
more people move which in turn creates
more of all those things
which again attracts more people and so
on
until they spill over into neighboring
cities or grow to consume them
entirely still there are limits
for example simple geography may support
several
centers of power like la and new york on
opposite coasts the other reason for
this growth ceiling are countervailing
forces
for example as cities like san francisco
grow demand pushes rent to untenable
levels
forcing an exodus in the opposite
direction
so while a country's largest city is
usually far bigger than its second
largest
this proportion varies based on many
factors like
economic development we can see this
fact reflected in this list showing the
ratio of a country's largest to second
largest city
its primacy ratio those larger cities
which are at least twice as large as the
next largest
are said to be primate cities they exert
outsized influence on the nation as a
whole and represented
almost exclusively to the outside world
for example
the greater london area is home to
nearly 10 million inhabitants
far more than second place manchester
similarly
mexico city is home to around 9 million
people
about 7 million more than any other
there are many other examples
including cairo paris jakarta and seoul
but without a doubt the absolute most
primate of them all
is bangkok thailand with at least 10
million people
depending on where you draw the
metropolitan boundaries
this dwarfs the country's second largest
city which has only 385
000 people that's a ratio of at least 26
to 1. no other large nation has a
population this
unbalanced and yet it's home to nearly
70 million people
meaning almost everyone lives either
around bangkok
or in one of its hundreds of small
distant cities
the capital magnetically concentrates
nearly every major institution
because where else would they go bangkok
is home to two large airports
one serving as the hub for international
flights and the other for shorter
regional ones
its 50 districts reportedly grow by as
many as a million people during the day
as workers commute from their homes
outside the metropolitan
area the city is also home to nearly all
of thailand's major universities
along with the vast majority of its
hospitals
altogether bangkok contributes 29
of the national gdp in 2010 it accounted
for 80 percent of
all urban land how does any of this
relate to hourly coups
that's where geography and politics
collide
because not only are all of thailand's
museums and schools here
but also all of its action it houses the
headquarters of all of its major banks
multinational corporations the national
stock exchange
national newspapers broadcast media
publishers
and most importantly branches of
government
bangkok singularly holds the country's
monarchy
military and bureaucracy which in turn
appoints all provincial governors and
district officers
for obvious reasons thailand has greatly
benefited from this close proximity
indeed many nations nurse primate cities
as a strategy for rapid development
hoping to later export their work across
the country
every financial or political decision
can be made and executed within a few
hours drive
there are no time delays or words lost
in translation
on the other hand there's also a
downside
bangkok is a single imperative choke
point
whose capture or disruption can cause
every category of chaos across the rest
of the nation
and small but symbolic and important
physical arteries
roads monuments and government buildings
are exactly the sites protesters seek to
occupy
and interrupt the area's unusually poor
city planning
or lack thereof ensures that many
streets are extreme bottlenecks
which if blocked can freeze entire
regions
all of these factors predispose thailand
to frequent coups
though not necessarily successful ones
since after the physically small
territory is captured it can easily fall
again of course geography doesn't solely
or even principally explain
thailand's instability there are other
political
and structural reasons which would be
foolish to overlook
for example its mix of democratic
institutions and unchecked royalty
creates inevitable tension but the
primacy of bangkok
ensures that when they do happen coups
are relatively
quick and decisive just as important the
extreme contrast and living conditions
opportunities and wealth between the
nation's capital and the other 85
or so of the country fuels the desire
for change in the first place
in other words the very same
inequalities which make revolution
possible
also motivate them as the rural
population craves the same attention and
resources as the city
while these facts do not necessarily
doom thailand to an eternity of course
they make real lasting change a slow
effort
still progress is very much possible
the latest round of protests has broken
the decades-long seal
on criticizing royalty opening the door
to honest and open debate
when structural progress is eventually
made it will be thanks to the
hard-fought protests
of today if you're interested in
politics you're probably curious to know
where the world is going next
and the best way to predict the future
is with math and logic
two things brilliant can teach you step
by step
this knowledge and uncertainty course
walks you through probability and a bit
of game theory
all in a visual intuitive and simple way
in fact i myself stumbled into this
chapter on which language is most
efficient while writing this script
and couldn't help but go through it
right then the magic of brilliant is
that you learn by doing
so the formulas and steps come naturally
through your own intuition
what you'll find is that learning can
actually be fun when it's done
right to start understanding the world
better and learn more about brilliant
go to brilliant.org polymatter and sign
up for free
the first 200 people that go to that
link will also get 20
off the annual premium subscription